this next segment is one of the most
embarrassing
humiliating segments i have ever seen
because it combines the pathetic
political perspective
and cynicism of fox news with
sending a reporter who has no business
speaking spanish to the border
to try to speak spanish fox news has
been playing up this narrative
that there's a crisis on the border that
was caused by joe biden it didn't exist
up until january 20th and that joe biden
and kamala harris are ignoring it
because they refuse to go to the border
this is
the story that they've been telling so
fox news sends a reporter
uh to the border to talk to people and
they decided to send griff jenkins and
griff jenkins
listen this is a guy who's been
embarrassing himself on fox news for a
decade
but he goes and talks to a random guy
who's just in the river and he's
believed to be in later we find out that
he is someone who helps get people
to the u.s mexico border who are looking
to cross into the united states it's
just a random guy sitting in the water
and up walks fox news reporter griff
jenkins
and tries to speak spanish and this you
just have to see let's look at the first
clip uh
check it out smuggler is coming over
towards us
i'm just going to take a moment and ask
him a few questions
hola come estas
more more los
now i don't even know what he said there
remember i'm a native spanish speaker
what i think i heard is more
los manos rather than las manos
mor los manos de ambre which
translates painfully literally as
more the arms of hunger and again i'm
like doing the best i can to make sense
of the syntax here
so then the guy has no idea what's going
on and is just sort of waving
and overwalks griff jenkins and this
continues
hablanglais no
contos
so there jenkins is asking in a very
strangely phrased way
how much are you getting paid for
helping immigrants
cross the border the guy says nothing i
think that
unfortunately as embarrassing as this is
the average fox news viewer sees this
and thinks wow this is like really good
investigative journalism this is great
stuff
and that's a media literacy problem as
much as this is a really hair brained
idea by fox
my guess is a lot of their core viewers
love this let's continue and this is my
favorite part
can i do say hello presidente biden
okay well neil he's not saying anything
about how much he's getting
paid or if he has a message for
president biden but
he does say that more people are coming
not entirely sure why
the smuggler is sitting in the middle of
the river here we're going to continue
to monitor it
and bring it to you as we get it neil
incredible i just love that because
first of all
why would this guy have a message for
joe biden
but i love that he says la presidente
biden which is the feminine form of the
question implying biden is a woman that
we have a female president
it's not on purpose it's not like this
guy's trying to emasculate biden he just
has no idea
how to speak spanish and this was a bad
idea from the get-go
so then apparently producers just loved
this so much they were the producers
were thrilled
so they they got more of this footage uh
fox news asking
a guy sitting in a river for his opinion
on american immigration policy
and joe biden
not coming for you so here the guy seems
to be saying
i only come to this point i don't go any
further
because that's beyond the border that
would be illegal i'm not doing that
and this guy is scared and i would be
too
and then jenkins again starts up with
the biden questions
see el presidente biden
habla frontera es serado
what jenkins is trying to say there in
some of just the worst spanish that i've
ever heard
is that joe biden says the border is
closed
and this guy responds but no one's
understanding each other and it's a
complete and total mess
is from
so the guy says well build the bridge
then people are tired
and the reporter says again but it's
closed the border is closed and the guy
says well open it
but it's not legal to go beyond the
river so that's why i stop here when i'm
helping people
but the best part of this is the guy
says
when asked for his message to joe biden
he says oh no we i have no problem but
you know do do what you're doing
you guys are good not exactly the
ominous threatening message
from coyotes that fox news wants us to
believe
and it continues getting more and more
interesting in mexico
la policia in mexico no no no
that is just the best the guy says you
know in mexico
the police are no good you guys are good
i respect you
uh i don't even think jenkins has any
idea the conversation that he's having
with this guy let's watch a little bit
more and
um
a see es
trabajando yeah so so then jenkins asks
why are you helping people cross and the
guy says
to help people that are struggling for
the american dream
he literally says for the american dream
because here in mexico
they're screwing people so a few
thoughts on this
first of all this guy is incredibly
sympathetic if you can
understand him which you know it you
really can't unless you speak spanish
because what's going there's no
translator it's just a pathetic mess
if the idea is to frame what's happening
as
really bad people helping really bad
people cross
it fails if you can understand what's
being said this guy is super sympathetic
to me
but more importantly no one really knows
because there's no translation this guy
speaks no english
griff jenkins speaks speaks essentially
no spanish
if you want to do this seriously you
could do it seriously
this is a sideshow they turn this into a
freak show
jenkins doesn't even speak spanish you
don't know
what the guy is saying uh and you you
really
can't actually do justice to a segment
that could be quite interesting
if you want to do this you bring in a
translator and you might actually have a
serious
segment here griff jenkins should be
ashamed of himself so should fox news
uh let me know what you think you can
find me on twitter at deepakman
whether you work in journalism marketing
pr
content creation or you're just curious
about what people are talking about on
the internet you've got to check out
thought leaders thought leaders has a
really impressive data platform where
they're scraping through hundreds of
thousands of youtube channels and
podcasts
and newsletters every day to see what's
being discussed
in the content and they take this data
and bring it together
in customizable graphs whether that's a
brand a person a topic
or anything else that you want to
explore so brands can see
where their competitors have been
mentioned content creators can see what
topics and themes are being featured on
other channels
marketers and agencies can see what
trends are on the rise before they plan
out their content strategy
and someone like me can use it to track
topics and news stories that are being
discussed the most
on youtube and podcasts and you can
access their data
for free that's free forever with no
commitment
sign up today create your own instant
trends report
now just use the link right underneath
this video